um but man I went on a radio station in
Toronto and they were like breezes top
five all-time right and I was like no
he's just not and and they were like
what and we got into the conversation I
said look like Elway did it with nobody
Marino did it with nobody like look at
the help that Drew Brees has had like
look at all the weapons around look at
the coaches and it's a bigger
conversation how do you separate an
all-time great player from his all-time
great coach right it's weird that Jordan
doesn't get mentioned with Phil Jackson
but Kobe gets mentioned with Phil
Jackson to go across sports but Joe
Montana well he had Bill Walsh one of
the premier fight callers of all time
right Oh
Terry Bradshaw Chuck Noll you know you
can't separate those guys right Bill
Belichick and Tom Brady I mean that's
gonna be an issue for like 40 years I
get it but Sean Payton and Drew Brees do
you separate how do you figure out you
versus all I don't think you can bear
basketball right basketball and one
player can change the game meaning
literally I mean LeBron goes to one team
and all sudden you go well they're one
of the favorites to the finals it
doesn't work like that in football
yes separating it is really hard to do
it really is and it takes a train died
to a degree I would I would argue that
it takes somebody that understands true
concepts of football and play calling
and things like that and I'm not trying
to demean anybody I'm trying to sit here
on a pedestal and be like oh I played
the game oh I joined the game when you
didn't III get that I'm not but but I
also need to take like some credit for
being taught by some really smart people
and offenses and I being around NFL
quarterbacks my whole life I have a new
take yeah that you could do that not a
lot of athletes can but I don't think
you having played the game helps you I
think you understanding how to watch a
game helps you definitely that's what I
think fans don't understand right
everybody can look at a football game
and see a 50-yard touchdown by Drew
Brees and go he's good the receiver is
good the defense is bad right which is I
feel like how fans watch the game right
but you are looking at keys you'll come
away from a first half with different
notes than just a fan watching it you
know how to watch it and I don't think
that's even just from playing it
I think it's from how you learned how to
study film ya know I think that's a huge
part of it my times and rooms with
Gruden day after day and josh mcdaniels
and breaking down film with the Patriots
and then hey knowing what's realistic to
ask of a quarterback because I did get
to experience that to a degree and know
what's easy and what's not easy for a
quarterback having you know the fact
that I've been on the field with people
like Drew Brees many times and Tom Brady
and Aaron Rodgers and I've seen Brett
Farr play right in front of me two
different times so what does that allow
you this I mean it allows me to see
their physical greatness or their
differences in physicality in person
which TV is not always going to do
justice a lot of people would say that
raises strength is not all physical
right breezes ability to see the field
breezes comprehension of the PlayBook
Brees his ability to be a coach on the
field yeah how would you respond to that
glad Stephanie would respond any one of
the great quarterbacks in the history of
football have all those qualities just
that's not greater in that than it then
the the lways the Mannings no Favre's no
not at all
no and and in fact I would say that's
where i would go with sean payton
lessons that argument cuz he just goes
here's Mark Ingram wide open three yards
but now that discussion sure so you know
that it's more Sean Payton and Drew
Brees because of I I know it's more
short because of the amount of easy
completions that are given the different
formations all the creative plays I
watch every weekend go oh that was cool
the ability to urge Sean Payton to dial
up screens and you go damn is he just
lucky or is he dial up the screen
against the most perfect defense every
time and so it's all those things added
to the fact of also would I always go
back to what do you do when the play
isn't perfect what do you do when the
play is not perfect and that's always
gonna happen to any quarterback on any
team a few times a game and you don't
think Brees when it breaks down is that
I think he's good he's not special I
would say he's out of both all-time
greats he's definitely not in the class
of some of the other all-time greats
when it comes to that I mean we
so saw Brady on Thursday night right
video came out from like our new
favorite guy be like Oh what an
incredible three yard pass by time rate
right there was like 15 to 20 plays sure
quick little check downs sure but I also
when I'm watching that I go you know you
need the right conductor to organize
them yeah execute yeah and it's so it's
this weird thing where you need a guy to
be like super polished at that right you
know what drew brees is completion
percentage of this season 70 to 78 yeah
he's damn near 80
like we freaked out when Sam Bradford
broke 72 years ago he's at 78% yeah it's
it's amazing and he's an incredible
passer and he's a really good athlete
and he does everything really good am i
shocked that he is throwing for over 70
percent not in the slightest
again I would say any of the 50 top 15
quarterbacks in football right now would
throw for 70% of that offense and it's
not a shot at him any of them would